on one corner we had Tony and Braxton
the two bunnies one didn't really like
me that much but the other one kept
eating the banana Tony Tony was cool in
the other corner there was Leo the dog
it was mellow but added a little bit of
like a spunk to him I assume the Tony
Braxton caretaker is really into books
Leo's owners probably I'm assuming the
more energetic one out of the two the
pet owner that I will be
meeting with is hello hi I'm Carolina
nice to meet you so do you want to go on
a date yeah let's do it we are done with
the first date
how would you say it went pretty well I
think you got my energy right I don't
think you you read Leo we'll see what
happens